oh hi
as nintendo gears up to release the wii
u i thought we should look back on one
of the aging wii console's most
neglected features that's right virtual
console now when nintendo first launched
the wii it was all about how you could
use it to download classic games from
prior eras of gaming but as the years
went on it started neglecting the
service look nintendo i get it okay
people don't really download games on
their wii okay i'm not gonna let's not
point fingers let's not worry about
whose fault it is okay it's yours but
let's move on with the wii u nintendo
has a chance to reinvigorate virtual
console here's five ways they can do it
number one
more games duh there used to be as many
as five virtual console games every week
in 2012 so far
15 not per week total and most of those
are neo geo games other platforms are
just neglected
are there more games to release on
virtual console of course there are of
the hundred best nintendo entertainment
system games rated by ign.com only 34 of
them are on the virtual console there's
tons more games out there from nintendo
and from third parties that would be
great fits
number two once you get more games on
there bundle them together look nintendo
if you don't want to have sales on
virtual console content why not offer
package deals offer the whole mario
series every game for 20 bucks or every
zelda game for 25 it doesn't devalue
your content it's just a new way of
buying it
yes we your long-suffering early
adopters already have these games but if
it gets more people spending more money
on virtual console you'll be able to
bring more new games for all of us
number three make games compatible with
3ds nintendo has already begun to sell
virtual console games on the 3ds
including ones that are already
available on the wii but once we move to
the wii u and there's a unified account
system across all your devices it's time
to let people buy the game once and then
play it anywhere
i'm not asking for things for free i'm
asking for flexibility with the content
that i already own you can verify it's
not going to change hands to a different
owner because i have one account
allowing players to buy the game once
and play it on all their nintendo
devices will give 3ds owners a reason to
buy the wii u and vice versa everyone
wins number four let us configure our
buttons
nintendo playing some of these old games
on controllers they weren't designed for
is either annoying or impossible let us
configure buttons especially on the 3ds
guys have you played new super mario
bros 2 that game that you released a
little while ago you know how you can
use the y and the b buttons to run and
jump okay well then let us do that in
regular super mario brothers if we want
to this is not rocket science if you
want to charge a premium price you have
to offer premium service
and number five is
ducktales that's right this deserved its
own category ducktales is one of the
best nintendo games ever made it's got
fantastic gameplay it's got catchy music
it's got graphics that are filled with
personality it is a game that is
emblematic of the 8-bit culture of the
1980s it has got to be on virtual
console the only snag is that the game
is owned by capcom but the characters
are owned by disney hmm
is there any precedent for re-releasing
a capcom game whose ip is owned by
disney of course marvel vs capcom 2. so
not only is it possible it's actually
been done before all capcom and disney
want is a sign from nintendo that it is
serious about bringing quality content
nintendo should be releasing the wii u
sometime around mid-november so let's
hope that it brings a reinvigorated
virtual console experience with it